hello um miss um yes I feel free to
interrupt me at any point to see Willie
Posey mikhastam on Cicero's hey I as as
as I was introduced I work at NASA we
have a lab just on the other side of
campus and we work mainly in climate
modeling so trying to put together
everything that we understand about all
the different processes that are going
on in order to understand the emergent
behavior of the climate and then
predicts baps what's going to happen to
it and I'm going to speak mainly about
the new developments in clown modeling
that I think make climate modeling much
more interesting for stakeholders like
yourself or for policymakers who have
very specific questions that you might
want to ask about the climate or a bad
policy or about vulnerabilities that up
until now people weren't really able to
help you give that workout that answer
so you can think of this as kind of
couples therapy for the marriage between
science and policy and we we work very
much at that interface right so trying
to oh you know what let me stand over
here that's right
we work in a field where there's a lot
of interest in that field outside of the
scientific community there would be a
lot of interests in it I think just
generally because it's a fascinating
subject but it's become much more
salient to policymakers to two
stakeholders and and so we find
ourselves thrust into a policy science
Malay which which can be very awkward at
times and I think historically I think
it's safe to say that hasn't always been
handled very well and trying to come up
with new ways to improve that dialogue
that process is really what I'm going to
try and focus on here there's a
fundamental disconnect basically
scientists speak in a very different
language than policymakers we're very
reductionist we're very okay let's break
it down to smaller and smaller
components whereas the questions that
are being asked of us are much more
holistic they're much larger scale
they're much more complex and we have
historically not answered those
questions in in that in that same thing
we've we've responded to holistic
questions like what's going to happen
with specific reductionist statements
about concentrations of carbon dioxide
or methane or aerosols and things like
that ah and so we have a fundamental
kind of disconnect that are more and
more people in the scientific end and I
think more and more people and policy
and are realizing I can be bridged and
I'll loop back at the end with some kind
of suggestions for how we can how we can
bridge that so what are the fundamental
issues okay so we're talking the same
language you're talking about climate
we're talking about policy we're talking
about emissions but things are framed
very differently from the scientific n
as from the policymaker and all the
stakeholder and we're very focused on
individual processes individual
constituents people spend their entire
lives trying to work out you know the
the the properties and an impacts of a
single molecule right I mean so there's
a very reductionist
that's the way we make progress um but
but this is not necessarily the most
relevant thing for policy makers or
stakeholders you know you want to know
what is this action going to do what is
what should what should i do a different
action should I what are the
consequences of anything I do we're
often very single issue whereas you know
policy makers have to multitask you know
somebody described being in Congress as
being forced to sit in front of a TV
channel with 500 different channels and
somebody else is turning the channel
every five minutes right so we're that
doesn't that doesn't work for us so
obviously policymakers are interested in
lots of other things not just climate in
air quality and pollution in public
health in agricultural yield in power
generation in you know the safety of
their people all of these things are
linked in the policymakers mind and
often in the scientists mind they're
completely set okay so we we set up a
process along with governments but but
mainly that is run by scientists I
called the IPCC that was supposed to
deal with this right there was supposed
to be the one stop shop that would allow
science to feed into an assessment
process which would then be used by the
rest of the world but that but the
problem is is not really with the IPCC
IBC there's very good science and it's
and it does a very good job at what it
does but but it doesn't quite do the
right job that's actually required and
mainly nets because the IPCC is an
assessment of the science by the
scientists for the scientists right and
if you've ever read any of the chapters
and maybe you've only read the summary
so if you actually dive into the
chapters you will see that that they're
not answering big questions they're
talking about the sites in the way that
we frame the science as scientists I'll
give you I'm not going to spend my time
shooting at the IBC see they do they get
they get far too much
lysergic yellow the government did
government so environment so into gum by
GE I see I'm not question but it's it
it's in English it's the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change but this is the group well group
international poor lame for her more
kima system okay I should I showed up
for a little thing that I'm not going to
shoot at it I think they do a great job
and and they get far too much criticism
but from people that have absolutely no
idea what they're talking about so I
think they do a great job but they do
get shorter but let me give you an
example of what I mean and and how those
different perspectives actually end up
confusing the issue so this is this is a
picture that was in the summary for
policymakers i think it was figure 1 or
figure 2 and what it does is it breaks
down all the things that have really
been going on since about 1750 arm in
terms of atmospheric concentrations of
various things so the biggest thing of
course is that common dioxide has
increased by over 100 ppm methane has
increased n2 always increased hair
carbon CFCs have increased with
increasing tropospheric ozone because of
emissions of reactive gases like knocks
and carbon monoxide we've increased
stars for water vapor we've increased
black carbon we've increased aerosols
sulfates nitrates organic aerosols those
have a cooling effect their blue all
these have a warming effect and if you
add up all of these things you get a
total net human activity which is very
large and very warming right so this is
basically you know why the planet has
been warming over the last hundred years
but this is very much a scientific point
of view we've broken up all the things
that we can measure and we've said okay
well that's responsible for this amounts
of radiative forcing this is responsible
for this amount and then we're just
going to add them all up none of the
things on here give you any guidance as
to how you might deal with
any of these issues right and the reason
is is that anything that you might do
affects half a dozen of these all at the
same time right a change towards
improving mileage standards in cars
changes ozone aerosols methane nitrous
oxide and carbon dioxide all at the same
time and is that a good thing to do or
is it a bad thing to do this this kind
of information doesn't help you at all
so this is this is very much the
scientists eye view of what's happened
so far um the key thing is that
different forcings are linked and
they're linked differently in different
regions so the linkage between emissions
from cars and power stations and smog
and climate and public health in China
is different to what it is at least earn
Europe because the the mix of emissions
is different the the fingerprints of the
technology is different and in and it's
different again in India where you have
a lot of biomass burning for domestic
burning of domestic cooking and things
like that so we have to start taking
that into account um now I'm going to
talk a little bit about climate models
and I'm gonna try and give you a sense
for how they are useful or if they are
useful um and so i'll start off with
with some things that i think that they
are useful for and i'll come back to
other things that i don't think that
useful for I think models as they exist
now are really good at helping us
quantify the impacts of various policy
choices now historically we haven't done
a lot of this kind of work but this is
the kind of work the models should be
doing instead of spending time worrying
about what any single factor does like
methane what does methane too we should
be thinking about what does this process
that we're engaged in what does fracking
do write it it causes emissions of
carbon dioxide but also there's leakage
of methane through the process that
methane oxidizes sets up a cycle adds to
ozone which is a controlled substance
under the EPA it changes the mix of
energy it changes where pollutants are
being emitted and so there are
consequences to actions that we can
quantify that aren't just what does any
one component of the atmosphere do it's
what does any one action do we can link
air quality concerns and climate
concerns are are much more easily now
the components that have been put into
climate models include atmospheric
chemistry aerosols different emissions
of many different species right now our
system models keep track of something
like 200 chemical reactions 60 or so
different species in the atmosphere
which is a huge expansion in what we
were doing in five years ago and they
can tell us something about why we're
going to need to adapt where where where
we're going to have vulnerabilities now
this is our you know people who make
global models aren't always very clear
about what the vulnerability is at some
locality or some regional area because
you know we don't live there we don't
really have much information but with
with can in conjunction with an
assessment of those local
vulnerabilities we can ask questions of
the models that might give us
statistical ideas about how the events
that give rise those vulnerabilities in
one region or another might be changing
over time and those are very specific to
different localities Texas is very right
now it's very clear is very susceptible
to drag right New York State not so much
New York State the problems are more
related to flooding or sea level rise
you know looking at what events cause
problems in different regions is very
much a discussion that has to be had
with the people who understand how
climate and weather impacts any
particular region and we can try and
assess the impact of known unknowns
right things that we know are uncertain
where we've got you know a parameter but
we know that we haven't been able to
constrain it very well we can test what
difference that makes if we change it or
we make it bigger or make it smaller or
we include a process
that we know might be important or or
might not all of those things can be
done with the models as they exist now
so what can't models do okay so models
can't give you perfect long-term or
short-term predictions right if if that
was something that you thought models
could do for you and they'll tell you
exactly what's going to happen in your
location at any particular time more
seasoned okay that's that's an
impossibility there's a certain amount
of uncertainty that's completely
irreducible partly that's scenario
uncertainty which obviously increases as
you go forward you know exactly how
economic develop how technology is going
to velop how emissions are going to
develop you know we can we can draw some
lines and we make some scenarios but we
don't know what is actually going to
happen by 2100 or even 2050 there's
irreducible uncertainty associated with
the chaotic nature of weather right so
you know we can have reasonable weather
forecasts of specific storms you know
five days seven days out but the idea
that we could tell you exactly what's
going to happen you know July
thirty-first 2014 is is obviously beyond
us but beyond everybody it's not
question it's not our skill that's
lacking it's just a fundamental
characteristic of the system um models
can't solve political issues right if
there are going to be winners and losers
if there are going to be costs and
benefits that's what the political
process is there to balance right models
can't tell you what's worth doing and
what's not worth doing right so we have
to make sure that the information that
we give doesn't pretend that these
issues are part of our algorithm they're
not right costs and benefits and values
there they have to be explicitly talked
about within the political context and
that has to be a much wider decision a
much wider discussion than just between
the scientists and the and the people in
power um and then going down to really
really really small scales kind of sub
hundred kilometers models are a long way
from being able to give you
detailed information at that scale right
there are some things that you can that
you can say at local levels there are
some things that you can kind of infer
but but really knowing exactly what's
going to happen in one particular
location you know where you have a power
station where you have a city that is
somewhat tricky and they can't tell you
what the unknown unknowns are they can't
tell you that we've missed something
crucial out about the system that
nobody's actually studied or seen yet
right then they're not they're not magic
you know they only respond to the
assumptions that we build into them and
so if there's new physics if there's
something new that is going to happen in
our new warmer planet um it's unclear
that the models will be able to tell you
so I think what's inevitable is that the
models are conservative with a small C
they will not include surprises that I'm
pretty confident we will have over the
next 50 years and I'll give you an
example of when that did that that was
exactly the case the polar ozone hole
over Antarctica and very recently over
the Arctic I was not predicted ahead of
time by anybody instead the the models
that were looking at ozone depletion
back in the early 80s showed a pretty
steady decrease in in ozone to the
extent that people were already worried
and they were already talking about the
Montreal Protocol but they didn't
include the chemistry that happens in
the polar vortex when it gets really
cold and you form these little particles
and there's a whole new set of chemistry
there occurs on these small particles
because they'd never been observed right
and that set up the ozone hole and led
to a great realization that you know
models are not crystal balls they can
only tell you what you've put in and
what you've already seen so what we're
trying to do it is something that is
actually very ambitious intellectually
ambitious what we're trying to do is is
just from a knowledge of all
small scale processes that are going on
the chemistry that that's going on
around us how clouds form how water
evaporates from the ocean how will the
winds push the ocean currents around how
soil moisture evaporates all of these
things we can go and measure them we can
we can kind of quantify them and then
we're going to put them all together and
we're trying to predict how the whole
system evolves just some just from
knowledge of the smallest scales and
it's not obvious that that is possible
but it does turn out to be reasonably
doable and so we're trying to predict
you know the climate ology why do we
have the seasonal cycle that we do what
what what controls the magnitude of
those variations we're trying to predict
all of those things just from looking at
all those different processes and then
we're trying to understand the
variability of that system right again
that variability is intrinsic to the
system it's an emergent property of the
system but it isn't something that's a
priority predictable just from you know
knowing that water evaporates from the
ocean that doesn't tell you what the
magnitude of different storm systems is
going to be in the northern latitudes
for instance and if that was just all
that we were doing I think that would be
a very interesting intellectual exercise
we'd have lots of people interested in
it because it's so complex but that's
not really why we're being funded we're
being funded because we humans are
kicking this system extremely hard and
for the Americans and the audience this
isn't the Democratic donkey it's kind of
generic donkey that's the symbol for the
Democratic Party but it's it's a very
bipartisan thing so we're all we're all
doing this and we're kicking this system
we really want to know what's going to
happen we all know what's in the box
what's the response of this system going
to be to the big kicks that we're giving
it so the kind of processes that we
include I gave a brief rundown earlier
on you know the interactions between the
ocean and the atmosphere instructions
and clouds the interactions between the
land and the atmosphere sea ice changes
changes in the ocean this is the kind of
stuff these kind of green things this is
the kind of stuff that was in climate
models say ten years ago right and so
we've matured as a science as a few
bored to the point where we've got a
pretty good idea about what these things
are doing and then we'd ask questions
well you know what if we change the the
power of the Sun you know there's an
11-year solar cycle you know what does
what what impact does that have what
impact does the big volcanoes have on
the site on the system what impact to
human influences on carbon dioxide and
things have on the system we could ask
those questions but what's happened over
the last five or so years is that we've
added funnel more complexity to this
we've added cycles that control methane
and the carbon cycle and aerosols and
atmospheric chemistry we're putting in
the response of ice sheets and glaciers
to changes were thinking about
vegetation in a much more sophisticated
way than we were doing before and this
has made the models far more complete
and in it and it's expanded enormously
the range of questions that we can pose
to the models so some of the key
atmospheric chemistry things um you
probably are aware of this I'm not going
to go through all of this basically
you've got you've got you've got a cycle
here which generates ozone o3 which is
the main main air pollutant that people
worry about and that's driven this
cycling is driven by surface emissions
of NOx coming from internal combustion
engines mainly but also emissions of
methane from for instance Gas Gas Works
and landfills and and agricultural
activity but also you could you know you
can put in here changes in carbon
monoxide all of these things make this
cycle faster and increase the amount of
ozone that's available and so we've got
a direct connections between surface
emissions of greenhouse gases like
methane and surface emissions of
pollutants to other greenhouse gases we
don't actually emit ozone it's just
something that emerges in the atmosphere
it's also that that's both the
greenhouse gas and a pollutant and that
in itself has an impact on how software
dioxide gets changed to sulfate aerosols
so this this is a big component acid
rain of course
as well as being a reflective component
of the atmosphere which is we're just
slightly cooling the atmosphere and of
course that feeds into carbon dioxide so
you can see that there's there are a lot
of linkages and this is not even like a
tenth as complicated as we're actually
calculating that make them make the kind
of questions that we're going to ask
slightly more interesting so remember
what I showed you at the beginning if
this is the same graph as as the one
from the IPCC except that I've rotated
it 90 degrees they're very fond of
flipping these things around I'm not
quite sure why but anyway this is this
is this is the same graph is what I
showed you before this is the carbon
dioxide contribution methane ozone
sulfate cooling nitrate cooling and
start will delay further slightly book
and instead of of saying well what's in
the atmosphere and what impact is it
having all right let's ask the question
what are we putting into the atmosphere
and what impact is that having and what
you see is that there are big
differences so remember that ozone is
not directly emitted sulfate is not
directly emitted nitrate is not directly
emitted stratospheric water is not
directly emitted instead we're emitting
carbon dioxide okay calm dog side is
pretty much are inert chemically so what
you put up is what that ends up staying
there but methane is very reactive and
so when you put methane into the
atmosphere you end up with more methane
in the atmosphere but you also end up
with more ozone you also end up with
more stratospheric water vapor and you
also end up a little with a little less
sulfate and a little bit more on nitrate
so the net effect of methane if you
think about methane being emitted as
opposed to methane being in the
atmosphere already it kind of doubles
the impact of methane in any of these
budgets so this gives you a much better
grasp of what it is that one should be
doing in order to reduce the abundances
of important species in the atmosphere
emissions come from many different
places and different emissions
from different how different different
different industries have different
fingerprints and emissions so for
instance biofuels particularly in Asia
produce a lot of carbon monoxide a
little bit of NOx and a fair bit of
volatile organics arm but don't produce
very much sulfate but industry and power
produce a lot more sulfate particularly
in Asia but don't produce very much in
the way of carbon monoxide and VOCs
because the combustion that goes on in a
power station is much more efficient
than the combustion that goes on in the
house or in a small industrial
environment so depending on what it is
that you're doing and where it is you're
doing it you have a different
fingerprint of emissions and so
therefore you're going to have a
different impact on air pollution
climate and then the net effects of all
of those things so I'll give you a
couple of examples some transportation
um if you look at the on road transport
sector so this is cars trucks and trains
what you're producing is carbon dioxide
from from the burning of the fossil fuel
are you producing knock ship reducing
black carbon which is an aerosol which
is absorbing so that's a warming effect
but is also particulate matter so that's
an important controlled substance for
environmental purposes and all of these
things are emitted at the ground level
they're domestically controlled so you
know it's a very kind of Tidy system if
you like aviation is is is is much more
of a mess carbon dioxide yes nitrous
oxide yes stuff with oxide yes you have
got also got contrails and water vapor
that's being emitted into the upper
troposphere and this is a very different
place from the ground there's a lot less
water there's a lot in the chemistry
that goes on in the upper troposphere is
different to what happens at the ground
and it's completely innocent
international business right so controls
on aviation and questions about how you
might deal with aviation pollutants are
very different to questions you might
have related to surface on road
transport and shipping is again another
another completely separate category
carbon dioxide mainly
but very high sulphur dioxide emissions
because the bunker fuel they use you
have very clear indirect effects if you
look at satellite pictures of you know
areas in the in the Pacific where
there's a lot of ship movement you'll
see clouds following the ship that
that's kind of similar to contrails
following airplanes and but this is in
the ocean it's often international
waters it's at the surface and is barely
controlled it'll so you can ask yourself
well what if we changed any of those
mixes what if we what if we were able to
take the on road transportation sector
so this is the net forcings from on road
transportation so this is positive
carbon dioxide ozone a little bit of
sulfate but not very much a little bit
of black carbon so those are the three
main components there and then you ask
okay well what about power generation
now this is on a 20 year horizon so if
you if you took a longer horizon then
carbon dioxide becomes more important
and then these elements here the carbon
the sulfates and indirect aerosol
effects on clouds they will become
smaller in comparison but if you
actually look at a 20 year horizon power
generation is kind of equal in terms of
its near zero in terms of radiative
forcing over a longer term then this
stuff drops out and this becomes a much
bigger term so long term power
generations is is a big driver of
climate change in the short term not so
much but you can ask yourself well what
would be the consequence of changing you
know cafe standards or switching to
renewable energy or something like that
and we can see what all these different
elements would would do so let's imagine
that that we could just buy a fiat our
reduced emissions from on road transport
by 50% either by my mandate or by new
technology what you'd have if you had a
zero-emission replacement source of
energy
that would obviously be the best you'd
have a big decrease in the radiative
forcings that would be a net cooling and
a net reduction of air pollution across
the board if you are such as we did it
in the in the u.s. if you did it
globally you'd still have a big net
reduction in in emissions and climate
forcing so that would be a good thing
right you can see the impact of
temperature changes so this would be a
clamp model simulation where we've
changed that emission profile by fifty
percent in the different scenarios that
we put forward and you can see that even
though you know this is something for
instance in this case we're only doing
in the US are you can see impacts
climatically that are actually
hemispheric and if you do it globally
then it looks more like the hemispheric
bias between southern hemisphere and
northern hemisphere you can see that
there's a big kind of global impact of
local changes um but you also have these
pollution impacts so this would be the
change in ozone that you would get if
you were replacing on road transport
with with hybrid fleets for instance
that were being powered by renewables
you'd have a decrease in sulfates and if
and this is the case here if you
replaced it using the current mix for
power generation and you'd still see net
reductions in ozone it's a little bit
patchy er but you have a big increase in
sulfates because current power
generation produces a lot of sulfur
dioxide particularly in Asia and you get
a big decrease in in in black carbon is
wrong okay so a quick summary you can
reduce the emissions from service
transportation and they will give you
unambiguous reductions in climate
forcing right that's it's one of those
win-win scenarios regardless of the
replacement power source you'd have
impacts on sulfates acid rain particular
matter ozone levels and that impacts
both public health and agriculture and
you know you can do this and lots of
different models and yours and you and
you get pretty much the same answer
regardless of what the models are or
where they
um so we take another step back and then
we ask ourselves well of all the
different things that we could tackle
which ones are the ones that are going
to give us the biggest bang for the buck
right arm this is a selection of
different sectors and different regions
so the first three are from North
America so domestic use of energy so
basically that's residential residential
use of energy service transportation and
power and industry okay so that's these
first three right now they produce
varying levels of carbon dioxide the
biggest source of carbon dioxide is is
industry and power and they produce very
different short-lived species impacts so
the short list species of the aerosols
ozone black carbon and they're like and
so when you put these things together
and you ask yourself okay well you know
should you have tackle the things with
the biggest carbon dioxide footprint or
should you tackle the things which have
the biggest net footprint okay the
answer is very different and it's
different depending on where you are the
other three here based on Asian patterns
of behavior so domestic burning agent
transport and Asian industry and what
you'll notice is that Asian industry
produces a lot more sulfate because it's
much dirtier and so if you look at the
the net impacts hear you say okay well
if you just looked at the carbon dioxide
you'd have said industry and power with
the two big things that you had to
tackle if you actually look at the net
impact what you find is the surface
transportation in north america and the
domestic burning of biomass or fossil
fuel in asia is by far the bigger
problem right so this would this would
give you a different perspective on the
on which policies you would want to be
tackling first
the intensity of right so so totally
tell me so so this the thirty percent
reduction that was just like okay well
what should what should we use because
we do this right so both I'll move to
next what's feasible and and what what
people have actually that the technology
exists and it's been probably costs
didn't everything the European
contribution looks very much like the
North American contribution it's the the
mix of sources and emission profiles for
different activities is quite similar
right so so it's the question is whether
you can have a feasible reduction in any
of these things okay so I said that
already so I'm just going to skip that
okay so very recently there was a report
that was there was commissioned by new
net to look at feasible reductions in
black carbon and ozone via emission
emission controls on particulates on
methane on carbon monoxide on volatile
organics where they did exactly what
you're saying what is actually feasible
in what location using what technology
and so what they did was they took
existing technologies that have been
deployed already in various places and
said well what would happen if we
deployed these things more widely and
they had three groups of measures are
one was just just controls on methane
that would be this this first column in
the different pictures the second group
of measures is the controls on methane
and then controls on black carbon so
this is like certain and an organic
carbon and then if you had the the third
scenario was if you control methane and
then you used all of the black carbon
reduction technologies that currently
exist and what they try to do is they
tried to go all the way down so you can
say okay well what impact of these
things going to have on climate right so
we can calculate the climate forcing
from that we can calculate the
temperature
changes rainfall changes and things like
that and you'll see that the more stuff
you do the bigger impact it had on
climate okay well that's not surprising
um but remember that these things also
affect ozone ozone is one of the key
problematic evolution species for food
and fur and for crop yield and so if you
are you could this is the annually
avoided crop yield losses in millions of
tons associated with these measures
which are changing ozone as well as
changing was as well as reducing climate
so you can see you can start to get
really very large numbers in here so
this is you know 50 to 100 million tons
of crop yield losses now what does that
cost right what's what's the what's the
what you know how'd it how does that
translate into into real dollars well
that's a little bit hard but we can get
to that 20 we can also look at human
health impacts ozone is is toxic
actually quite low concentrations and is
very clearly affected affects human
health and so as you start decreasing
the amount of ozone decreasing the
amount of black carbon you get you end
up with estimates of annually avoided
premature deaths in the millions of
lives okay and then you can say okay
well just these little ones these little
things that we can actually count what
would be the benefit of that Bobby the
the cost savings in that and you end up
very very easily with numbers in the two
to five trillion dollar range right and
this is far more than any of the
abatement mechanisms would actually cost
so unep is the united nations
environmental program so if you I gave
this as one of the the links to read and
and I really recommend it because it's
um it's an assessment that is far more
tied towards policy makers and
stakeholders that any previous climate
assessment has been because they did
they answered the questions that real
policymakers are answering as opposed to
answering the questions that scientists
think policy makers are answering
so um okay so how do we go forward with
this kind of thing I think that the
biggest thing that we've learnt in
producing these assessments and in
demonstrating to people what these
models can do is that we really need to
spend a lot of time listening to what
the other people are asking and and
thinking about what it is they're really
asking because often the questions a
malformed and we kind of interpret them
in our own way and we answer the
questions that we thought you should
have asked okay but that's we need to
spend more time listening there's no
escape from the complexity of the system
I think this is a very important point
the system is complicated air pollution
and climate change and public health all
of these things are linked right so that
you know we can try and kind of you know
separate out you know read we can try
and separate out quiero we can try and
separate out black carbon but but in the
end that's that's not sensible because
we have to decide on specific actions
and any action that we take has impacts
on all of these different things a
climate change is a problem that infects
all other problems because we rely
implicitly to it to a large extent on
assumptions about static climate in a
statistical sense for the many many
different things where we grow our crops
how we grow our crops where we build
buildings you know how close to the
shore we go how close to the river we go
our weather you know I mean you have a
lot of power stations on rivers that are
affected by changes in rainfall and you
know there are there are issues with how
climate impacts rainfall which impacts
power generation all the way down the
line we can be policy neutral as
scientists but we need to be policy
specific it's not signal it's not it's
not enough just to say we have to reduce
carbon dioxide emissions that's true but
it
all you do this how you can do this in a
sensible way how you can do this in ways
that don't make other problems worse
those are questions that we can help
answer but we can't determine obviously
what policy is actually ever what
policies actually get adopted so to
conclude our system models and I haven't
really shown you any any big flashy
graphics or anything but what I could I
should than that assistant models I
think can provide key input into policy
choices we can do sector and policy
specific scenarios not just the generic
business as usual kind of scenarios that
the IPCC has has promoted we can
calculate the coherent responses of
atmospheric chemistry air pollution
particulates and what ends up happening
when you do that is that you you can
build wider coalition's for any
particular course of action because you
can see that any particular course of
action has implications that are much
wider than just how much carbon dioxide
is in the atmosphere um we certainly
need to do more work on building
appropriate Diagnostics particularly
when we start to get down to the
regional level or what is it that people
really are sensitive to you know you're
nobody is really sensitive to the global
mean temperature you know you're
sensitive to rainfall in this watershed
you're sensitive to you know the number
of days above 30 degrees c in this
locality you know you're sensitive to
things that aren't necessarily the
standard Diagnostics that we always
produced um there's a lot of work that
is happening but that work is happening
outside of the IPCC framework and I
think it's very important but for
stakeholders such as yourself to realize
that the scientific community doesn't
just speak through one math piece right
there's a lot of different work that's
going on there's a lot of different
studies that are going on and are lots
of different perspectives that that if
you can go out and look for them you
might find to be are much more
appropriate for
your needs I think IPCC is very useful
it does a very good job of what it does
but but as I said at the beginning you
know IPCC is run by the scientists for
the scientists if you want science for
policy it's not necessarily the place
that you'd want to go so you know to
basically conclude scientists and
policymakers you know we just need to
talk and and that goes to stakeholders
to so that's that's that's for you okay